[Music]
okay I don't think Tyco would do this
but I could see tyka doing this I'll
tell you if he delays I like it with
Tyco flexes all right so this
five-year-old little boy he was caught
driving his parents car on a freeway
five years old freeway car how big is
this [ __ ] how can you reach the
pedals five heroes freeway card the
freeway sounds like a Chandler moment
you don't fit my role to a car okay so
he was in Utah
all right apparently he was on his way
to California to buy himself a
Lamborghini with three dollars he's
ready to negotiate yeah this kids really
smart and really big yeah okay so what
is he driving a [ __ ] Mini Cooper
there's that photo oh it's a big car I
don't know the make of the car but there
is this photo of him and he does not
look [ __ ] five like this is a big kid
center to space this is it five years
old what the [ __ ] are they feeding him
oh but it reminded me of Gio's nephew
he's a big kid so Jill's nephew that
dude the one that's Tigers age no no no
like that all the oldest one he's I
think maybe I think when you were he's
probably like already like a hundred
pounds when he was like six or seven
yeah looks like that you mean the big
boy yeah he's a big kid a big boy when
when he was he used to come here play
video games right no uh that's Jill's
Jill's brothers kids oh that one that
guy's a big big boy the older brother
yeah yeah so um I can't believe his
little kid did that illness of the
parents and it
being interviewed right and then they
were like yeah the angle that the photo
is taken it does like make them look
older but he's five years old yeah I
don't think I could have reached the
pedals at five [ __ ] no this is why you
got to keep all cars stick shift
so he's stupid ass [ __ ] kids can't be
stealing your [ __ ] pretty neutral yeah
but you don't go anywhere just gonna
slow these cars away put it on reverse
put on Drive like so I didn't know how
to [ __ ] shift the gear that means
he's been planning this he was like I
want to get that Lamborghini I'm going
to California and I'm gonna study how my
mom uses the car and he's like been
taking mental notes I think at that age
they finally watched especially now the
knowledge that you have online google it
you could you to be I think kids now can
spell did you watch the video well I
think cop arrested or pulled him over
oh there I didn't do it my knees taught
herself how to read at 3:00 yeah
so they have from the cop car they
basically you see the kid like all the
cars are moving around him right and
then he's like going in between lanes
I got the video wait is this the same
kid where they gave him a Lamborghini to
ride what I don't think so no wonder you
wanted her to give the video you gotten
tasted all down [ __ ] got a [ __ ]
huh you tracted [ __ ] wait so he's in the
SUV
yeah isn't according to firaon soon
that's a son that driving for five this
is [ __ ] amazing like how emerge I'm
actually pretty good for five I don't
know
so I remember even driving like at like
14 and 15 or a car merges into my lane I
start freaking damn ease you think no I
see mom he knows how to use this [ __ ]
[ __ ] three lanes on oh my god what
the [ __ ] whoa
the cards which I want no one else do
the three the one that went over there
now that should swerving too much credit
this seems much still this kid still
knows how to drive Wow also you actually
pulled over he knows too much about cars
man you've been studying telling Drive
earlier you go get it oh I get the
kidding we're holding it let me see the
cops face when he just purposely did
let me scrub I think the bow was a
confidence it'll be extra scare i buy
put your handle [ __ ] right [ __ ] now
Mike is there like another guy behind
him holding on sister and well open all
the goddamn the cops interview yeah and
he's like at first I was like it this
can't be like because we're watching and
I okay usually drunk driver that sort of
a little bit that yeah yeah this was
like way more impaired than a drunk
driver yeah and then a paranoia is that
the crate yeah yeah and then they see a
he goes up to the car and you say what
the [ __ ] he's like how do you in the
case of five is you go up to the
consul's elbow and bubbles and [ __ ] it's
in the car seats though imagine had the
foot he install the car seat into the
driver zone the cop would not have found
him that's a good driver
yeah so the main question is how did he
even know where the Lamborghini
dealership was I know like the DPS a
Lamborghini be a Los Angeles Lamborghini
he was going where it just they just
said to California to get so he wasn't
from California who you talk he was in
Utah a whole three bucks is gonna get to
bottom Clark
Utah dude I know it's [ __ ] crazy they
did say he made it a handful of miles
from like the fact that you even emerged
onto the freeway
that's insane that's [ __ ] Balaji
merging onto the few and expertise got
my license he's scary
oh yeah I just take surface streets
everywhere but I think I have five
though I wasn't that scared I would have
probably drove cuz you don't know the
consequence your mortality yeah was he
no consequences really oh [ __ ] yeah
five village I wouldn't be able to see
over the dashboard also small yeah
that's impressive
what did you guys learn how to drive
when the first time I sat behind the
wheel I think I was you loved it Oh
first time I ever sitting behind a wheel
yeah like a little little kid but I was
like on my mom's lap you know we're
trying to try to ski with my dad all the
time in the parking lot whatever no he
was just just drive the roads so I think
back then it was like super linear like
seatbelts weren't mandatory you could go
still okay to ride in the truck the
table got picked up from elementary
school like that yeah it was like the
rules are way different so my dad would
just drive around while like hotbox in
the car with the cigarette I got the
free secondhand store how about like to
drive drive like like by yourself
I tried stealing my mom's car and I was
like 10 or 11 and then that's when I
realized it was like actually scary
because I put it in Drive and I didn't
know car moves on its own so when I was
in the garage I kind of crashed into the
mattress that we had leaning in the
ocean I put it back in like park and it
just freaked me out and I went back
inside I wait till my mother showering
to pull the keys off so she'd even know
until this day so you we reversed the
car back or like your mom discover it
like crashed into the mattress yeah
that's probably there for her own driver
[Laughter]
my mom like looking at the car like wait
what the hell she's like I guess I
parked the district's actually drive
drive a car was my best friend's mom her
van and we were in the alley she was
like oh come on girls you guys can drive
or whatever and then the second time was
in my aunt and I've never driven with
either parent actually I learned how to
drive with my aunt my best friend's mom
and my boyfriend hmm yeah what um how
old is fifth grade 10 10 11 I think
that's when I learned you know back then
you can drive out like 14 mm-hmm yeah
when's back then with the pink slip yeah
Oh in an Wednesday look then like 90s or
you still cuz I thought that that was 15
and a half as one they raised it
oh they raised it cuz I had my pink slip
when I was 14 I had a pink slip - it was
tight I think now it's now it's eight
years
no no well at least when I was in school
like I think it was 15 and a half is
when you could get a pink slip yeah
maybe 16 was when you got your license
for six months
like permit they probably raised it for
us what do you mean for us yeah when we
got to our a is like it was race like 50
you know you could do mortar cycle ad
before that though there's like doing
dick dirt bike I don't know about
motorcycles no you could you can your
get dirt dirt but you know back then cuz
in no in elementary school my friends
already had motorcycles yeah you can you
can do it as long as it's not a license
the vehicle so like you can get like
dirt bikes you can get like like
motorized bikes and stuff and they all
it's all that wood right as a dirt bike
to school yeah as long as it's a small
enough CC might be like under 50 CCS or
something right cuz it's number yeah I
was probably Street not street legal but
they would just [ __ ] ride that [ __ ]
and it was so cool like keep inside whoa
yeah and then my buddy was like 14 or 15
at the time so he had his pink slip and
then he took me to a parking lot and he
just taught me how to drive
at fifth grade so we were in the [ __ ]
family man I was just parking and I was
like it was the funnest [ __ ] in the
world and then my other buddy at like 15
or 16 he had those drift cars and we had
a huge grass field behind the church and
after church he taught me how to drift
and that [ __ ] was pretty fun so I think
I've been driving a lot like from that
time and now I'm thinking back I'm like
a lot of people don't get to do that now
unless maybe like in another state or
whatever like where it's kind of country
people don't drive even now like my
nephews they didn't bother getting their
license until like 18 yeah yeah I think
my sister drives she's 21 really I think
my brother's too impatient that teacher
if she wants to learn boy brother keeps
yelling at her whenever they drive and
she gets scared that's not crazy because
I like the
independence of it me too yeah but in
you're not driving so people that are
like like I don't like being having to
depend on someone else it's like if we
take it a little bit back right it's
like me owning my horse if I need to go
somewhere jump on the horse versus the
mentality these days like I'll just jump
on my neighbor's horse where I'm from
well now it's like are you going
somewhere I'll be fine on the back
everything is on that face but yeah so
like to get to Facebook and like okay
they will also work at Facebook all over
stre no point yeah like everyone there
works for like Silicon Valley and stuff
so it's like everything so they're so
smart out there like everything's
integrated there's a car pool things
that come pick up there's buses that
come take you to your job so it's like
over there you know they you need a car
you go over but like to get your Josh by
like 50 bucks yeah
did you ever when you first got your
license like what try to park like
perfectly I would practice parallel
parking all that stuff all day that's
one thing that I've always been really
proud of I'm like I'm just naturally a
really good parallel park you know since
the very first time [ __ ] nailed it
and I got Tesla now you don't need it
you know no I never use the auto part
cuz it's [ __ ] it takes forever and it
actually gets way too close right again
nervous where I'm like let me just do it
myself
you'll be shot parallel park in the RV
[Music]